and now here are the nominees for
achievement and sound mixing baby driver
during later Tim cavity and Mary a
chalice blade runner' 2049 Ron Bartlett
Doug Hemphill and Matt Ruth
Dunkirk Reglan Baker Gary a Rizzo and
Mark Weingarten
the shape of water Christian cook Brad
Doorn and Glenn Bhatia
star wars the last Jedi David Barker
Michael semanek Ren Kleiss and Stuart
Wilson
and the Oscar goes to Dunkirk Raglan
[Applause]
the second women fifth nomination
and the first Oscar and forth
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I like to thank ladies and gentlemen of
the Academy of Arts and Sciences thank
you so much for bestowing this great
honor upon this sound crew for Dunkirk
to my support team Catherine land a cur
I love you too
to my cheerleading squad Carrie Cashman
Jim grace and Jake to two gentlemen that
bookend my career Don Rogers given me
flight and to kim hua for giving me a
safe landing to Christopher Nolan that
entrusted us encouraged us to try to
make a difference in a soundtrack thank
you so much Jessie and Oliver I love you
Chris Nolan thanks for making such a
great movie that everybody saw it and
got to hear our work thank you everybody
thank you Academy to my daughters
Luciana and Devon I love you hang on to
your dreams they are so so valuable in
to everybody at Full Sail University and
my family way up there somewhere I don't
know I love you I love you so much thank
you
[Applause]